President Trump says he looks forward to
working with Frances newly elected
leader Emmanuel macron the centrist
scored a resounding victory over far
right candidate marine lepen he won
about two-thirds of the votes cast at 39
years old McCrone becomes france's
youngest head of state since Napoleon
this morning he joined France's current
president at a ceremony make marking the
end of World War two in Europe
mark Phillips is in Paris with what the
election results mean for France's
future mark good morning good morning
well president Trump may have
congratulated the new president-elect of
France to Immanuel back crawl but during
the campaign he actually tweeted that he
thought the various terrorist attacks in
France would help his right-wing
opponent marine lepen
he was wrong the winners strode on stage
to give his victory speech accompanied
by Beethoven's Ode to Joy the European
anthem the loser tried to dance her
blues away - I love rock and roll she
couldn't have loved the numbers Emmanuel
macron is a 39 year old former
investment banker who had briefly been a
cabinet minister but had never run for
office before with both the left and the
right of French politics rejected by the
voters he came up the middle in a 66 to
34 win that can only be called a
landslide many thick black Ross said he
understood the anger of those who had
supported his far right-wing opponent
and would work for them - viva la
république but it's hard to see how the
principles of marine lepen nationalist
anti-immigration National Front can be
accommodated by a factor of two to one
the French had chosen macros moderation
overlap ends extremism in the French
system voters are given two ballots each
with one candidate's name on it they
vote with one and throw the other way
trash bags across France were full of
rejected scraps of paper with marine
lepen name on the news is not all good
for Emmanuel macron he appeared at a VE
Day commemoration with the outgoing
president Francois alone and he now
inherits all the problems that undermine
the alone presidency Emmanuel macron ran
his campaign on a completely different
set of policies to Donald Trump and to
his opponent marine lepen
she campaigned on protectionism closing
borders he argued for an
internationalist approach and economic
reform and Gail he won all right Mark
Phillips reporting in Paris thank you
Mark